dave chappelle gets attacked on stage at
the hollywood bowl the netflix is a joke
festival
um can't let chris rock have nothing
you know what i mean like
i've had a month bro he got a month
right he was the guy
i think he paid for it really take alex
media i think he paid for it come on i
mean worth the money yeah but
do you really think though
no
and yeah like and he had kind of funny
lines to say after it like in that
moment you're shook somebody runs up on
stage and apparently the dude had like a
weapon or whatever yeah like wearing a
knife
shaped knife now do we have no right now
we're recording this on wednesday so we
don't have all the information about
this guy i'm sure they're going to go
through his tweets and find out
everything he ever did etc and we'll
know that very soon but um it looks like
it's something similar to this
oh my god that's crazy [ __ ] so wait he
like whoa whoa barely had that on him
when he was arrested like oh it was on
his body but he wasn't like attacking
dave with it that's yeah they're not
sure but that's what it seems like do we
know anything about this guy
like do we know what community he's part
of isaiah lee
23 years old i just saw that he wasn't
white and i was like
he could be tan he could be tan white
isaiah was the last time he met a white
isaiah
good point apparently he had a
social media following according to this
article from tmz he had 32 000 followers
and only follows 80 people dave
chappelle being one of them
hmm and what is his vibe like he'll get
more followers in there yeah what does
he do
i mean look at him
goddamn sunny asian
he looks a little bit but he also got
punched in the face a lot so that's
that's right
yeah they're just a little bit more
clothes from the repeated punches in the
face we're not taking it we're not
taking another one well you're not
taking another why do black males hate
comedy why do black males hate black
comedy
why why black males hate black comedy
asian men hate comments on black comic
crime yo black or black crime with the
comedy world man
this is disgusting watch out with them
jokes you get it too i'm just saying but
is it i mean i don't want it to happen
anybody
we got two more shows left on this tour
infamous tour is almost over you got two
more chances in vancouver to get me
follow what
don't get me i don't want anybody to get
me it is just a wild time man [ __ ] i
don't know what do you guys think about
it so some people are blaming will smith
okay where they're like oh this is will
smith's fault he normalized attacking
comedians and he slapped the comedian
that everyone cheered blah blah blah i'm
like i don't really think that has
anything to do with it
it's not it's his fault it's just people
don't do things because uh they're
normal they do things for attention and
will smith doing it got crazy attention
this is gonna get crazy attention more
people will continue to do it as long as
it gets the attention it's like the uh i
don't know if they said this about
school shootings or like
or
terror but they said the more the media
the more the media puts it out the more
they end up happening right like copycat
[ __ ] basically yeah cause you get
attention from it exactly and this kid's
gonna get crazy attention apparently
he's a rapper
uh oh that's yeah and apparently he has
a song called dave chappelle yeah it's
just such a weird thing man i think it's
good he got his ass beat though yeah
that president should be set if you [ __ ]
with a comic on stage you will get your
ass beat yeah i mean they [ __ ] him up
but some people were mad at david bill
because apparently he came out and he
said oh i stomped him backstage i always
wanted to do that or something like that
why are you mad at him for that people
are like oh like why are you jumping in
no he said they're stomping him
backstage now oh i thought he said that
i stomped him yeah i think he said he
stopped him well if you watch the video
the he's he doesn't leave the stage ever
oh really yeah
he's they stomping that he is he he says
a really funny line he goes uh he goes
thank god that was clumsy
like what a great word you know like oh
it's just [ __ ] hilarious man son that
really does show the difference between
rock and chappelle right what rock is
just in complete shock and then just
goes well smith just slapped the [ __ ]
out of me
all right so we're here to give the best
documentary
chris rock got his revenge though
uh because he came on on the mic and he
was just like yo was that will smith
yeah he did pop in
one
months later that's the best [ __ ] you
got bro he's waiting to get paid
why are you gonna put it out just for
like whatever he's like oh i could just
take this to netflix no but he did
apparently i put out clips every week
chris wrong's already chris rock you
know what i mean son weak
come better
come back i'm better so i mean it's like
off the cuff like another person got
attacked like you're not like right in
bits to be like all right when someone
else gets attacked here's what i'll say
i'm just saying he should have came back
he still hasn't he still hasn't lit up
will smith it is true he has not i think
he's just he's legit old news now he's
not even the most recent comedian to get
attacked on stage yeah
that's funny yeah you still haven't
responded he's on some kardashian [ __ ]
like stuff happens to kardashians and
then they do a show about it four you
know four months later no you know and
then they cash in on them yeah if you're
chris rock that's exactly who you want
to be compared to
yeah yeah good call but now though he's
like 55 like he doesn't want to be in
that like rat race social
yeah 55 year old dude yeah
like what what are you thinking he's
gonna have a documentary about it
how is he gonna make money about this
he'll do a comedy special but he's gotta
work it out so you're saying he goes
into the clubs works it out in the clubs
yeah and ideally stuff doesn't leak or
he'll put people's phones on cases uh
and he works it out and talks about it
he like does an exclusive whatever and
then gets paid for it that way but i
hear he's not working at any joke yeah
about will yeah i don't know if he isn't
that's whack that's wow that's the
whackers whatever he's the [ __ ] goat
and that's whack yeah well dave that's
why dave's the goat well we'll see if
dave works it out
dave's already hoping yeah he might have
better jokes about will smith slapping
chris rock than chris had
he's been workshopping
god damn why the [ __ ] wouldn't chris do
it i don't know man
he's just so [ __ ] robotic about his
process and that's great it's gotten him
some of the best specials of all time
but this is a time when i think you need
to disengage from that you know what i
mean is that your king he also might be
[ __ ]
my god
he is my guy
he might be [ __ ] up for real though
man
will smith slapped him on live
television he might it's like oh bro you
got to say something he might be like
bro he might still be like bro i don't
even know how i
fee feel i can't get my big heart he
probably can't get hard and [ __ ] she's
like there's a slap so that's shut up no
it's not
a regular slap that's not a regular
that's not a regular [ __ ] fresh
prince of bel air slapped you at the
oscars in front of the world that's
different and you're the god you're a
god you are a god to people and it's
like nah [ __ ] you can bleed like it's
like when the persian king got hit with
a little bit that's all i needed to do
was show that you ain't bro you ain't
that oh no and now look at everybody
we're [ __ ] on chris rock but that's
you can't we're just [ __ ] on him and
it's because it's funny he's a [ __ ]
god in the thing that we do yeah that's
how like bro that's not a normal slap
you know what a good place would be to
to talk it out is the stage
they're the best yeah i mean if you want
to work things out you could do that on
stage i can't at least hear a reason why
he doesn't feel comfortable doing it i
heard he just said the hour is written
or some [ __ ] like that
come
a on for us obviously selfishly like
yeah he wants to put the hour out in the
way that he wants to put it out sure but
like
selfishly we're like now we'd like to
see you talk on this at a certain point
you got to talk about it yeah what i
mean
ah that's uh that's unfortunate
damn man yeah it is wild you think that
this will continue to happen oh yeah
really for a little bit yeah it's gonna
be a thing oh [ __ ]
yeah better watch out i don't know about
you i'm a great fighter so i'll be all
right
are you at all concerned
i you know what i used to say even
beforehand was like i'm not trying to
hurt anybody's feelings so if you legit
don't want to be talked to just give me
a little thing and i'll move on yeah i
hate that awkward [ __ ] where somebody's
like yo shut the [ __ ] up move on and
then we got to do that and i gotta
pretend i'm ready to fight you even
though we both know i'm not you know
what i mean yeah yeah so i'll say that
[ __ ] early on in shows like as i'm
teasing somebody i'll be like yo by the
way just thing if you don't want to be
talked to that's fine just let me just
give me one of these i'll move on so i
think it disengages a lot of that [ __ ]
but that is a thing i've had to think
about being 5'7
for years doing comedy talking [ __ ] to
people yeah like you got to be wary of
the line and i you know you genuinely
don't want to hurt anybody's if chris
knew jada was a witch he probably
wouldn't have said that [ __ ] yeah that's
true
that's true no no that's a good ass
point
yeah that's a good yeah
yeah
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip because
i gotta tell y'all about lucy look we're
all adults here right and i know some of
us choose to use nicotine to relax focus
or just unwind after a long day lucy is
a modern oral nicotine company that
makes nicotine gum lossages and pouches
for adults who are looking for the best
most responsible way to consume their
nicotine it's a new year why not start
it out by switching to a new nicotine
product that you can feel good about
i'm telling you
is the best
it's the best the best it's not even
close it's not even close you want that
nicotine hit lucy's got your back that
that lozenge bro
it's
it's p bro
you're pushing the velocity
is absolutely pushing p if you enjoy
using nicotine you should definitely
check out lucy's products at lucy.co go
to
lucylucy.co and use the promo code
flagrant you can get 20 off all the
products on your first order including
the gum or lozenges that's lucy.co and
use the promo code flagrant at checkout
now listen
i also have to read this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical okay
so remember if you're interested in a
better way to use nicotine visit lucy.co
and be sure to use the promo code
flagrant now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon clip you can find a
whole episode and join the [ __ ] army
at patreon.com flagrantsu are we gonna
are we gonna go through a time where
like
comedians start being victims
like oh we're under attack and
yes
yes we do that all the time that's
always good
that's all we do that's part of the
perks of the job i don't mean they say
jokes anymore i can't say words
i'll be doing that [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] is
that what we do yeah are we just crying
ass [ __ ]
black people you see how you want
yeah i'm wondering like
what do we do with this
what do we do with this as comics i
think there's probably more security
like really high level shows yeah i
think you got to set the president of
beating the [ __ ] out of people who walk
on stage how does bro get through with
the gun knife
dc on fly the guy walking stage knocked
his ass out knocked his ass
out and it didn't go back to jokes like
stood there and let everybody know like
i will [ __ ] all y'all up
with that thing yeah i love it how do
you get in with that yeah that's
ridiculous the hollywood bowl
you know what i mean that's [ __ ] wild
though yeah that is absolutely
ridiculous that's crazy this is from tmz
now do we know anything about this guy
and is is he was he upset about the
trans stuff like what was he upset about
it doesn't seem like there's a there's
no motive yet motive no talking about
that psychotic episode
what
no no the psychotic episode right
that's kind of interesting this is why
this will continue to happen
people will continue to have psychotic
breaks and now they have an outlet for
that psychosis
attacking comedian just wasn't something
existed so they don't think about doing
it they're like oh let me shoot up a
school or let me go yell at people on
the street or let me go jump in a
[ __ ] dumpster or something this is
just another thing you can do now you
know what i'm saying like the school
shooting [ __ ] became a trend it's not
like it always existed throughout
history it's a tick tock challenge
yes
so this is a new tick tock challenge
essentially for crazy people crazy
people are going to start to see that
this is something you can do and can get
attention for and you're fighting the
good fight or whatever and once that
psychosis starts spinning there's really
no stopping it yeah so 100 that's gonna
happen again also what's really
interesting to me is at the at any level
we're talking about the oscars and the
hollywood bowl yeah you know what i'm
saying because in your head as a comic
you do like like you say when that if
you know the funny bone you're getting
killed yeah exactly but i'm expecting
that too i'm like there's nobody in the
security but i'm at the house security
don't even tell him to stop talking you
gotta go yo can you tell us table seven
to shut the [ __ ] up please let's just do
it on stage and i gotta kick them out
from on stage
you are done bro you in a tux at the
hollywood bowl bro you there is a level
of like all right this i'm beyond that
now yeah no one's gonna run up here yup
so that's what's crazy to me is that
like bro the boldness to do this [ __ ] at
any kind of venue is like huh well
that's definitely new getting up on them
stages isn't easy
like those stages of the theater like
that [ __ ] like hike your pants every
time every time we're on the team
every time we're at a theater they put
security standing up on stage you go i
don't want them standing i don't like
them like they're staring at the crowd
they're judging them i like them to be
something else now they're going to be
there with me
sit right there they shouldn't be like
def jam or [ __ ] at the cocktail
table
that's going to be my security air
marshal air marshal but it's just like
some guy that's hanging out on the stage
like a photographer but he's strapped
yeah
yeah
secret photographer and i've been taking
pics yo that's great right 100 yeah i
mean [ __ ] man vala
two more shows boy
i'm gonna need to see all that karate
you'll be fake practicing around the
studio
[Laughter]
boxing bro you know what i'm saying i'm
gonna need you to do that
someone pulls up didn't he have
something happen at a show rogan
i remember one time the lights went out
and just how serious that was
just that moment of like [ __ ] because he
was on stage and you could just you
could feel it from him too just like
[ __ ] like yeah because it's like with
him he's the joker in this [ __ ] like
yeah it's really happening or it's like
is china in this [ __ ]
whoever's mad at this [ __ ] today
because people
hate him
for real and hate and psychosis is a
terrifying thing and that's the thing
that happened with with chappelle it's
[ __ ] start day for the first
time in my life
people started to hate him it was
different when he went to africa
[ __ ] didn't hate him they're
like is he crazy like what's going on
yeah this was
hate yeah
and if you're a crazy person and you're
filled with hate yeah that's a dangerous
combination there's also like a god
thing
because i think a lot of things look joe
like a god too yeah exactly like dave is
like a hero he's a goat he's like bigger
than a human being but he's also hated
by some people and like there's like a
rift you know what i mean i feel like
crazy people uh for how much he's
celebrated those people that hate him
hate him even more now maybe yeah if he
was just some stranger
hater you know it's hard to hate
somebody that's not that oh yeah i
wasn't i wasn't implying that everybody
hates him like a community started to
hate him i don't think there was any
community people might have been
apathetic towards him they might have
gone oh that's not my favorite comic
yeah but nobody was like i hate that guy
for how funny and awesome his jokes and
movies are people say that people say i
hate david i hate jeff i hate that yeah
you're right nobody should say i hate
the fear factor guy
who hated the fear factor guy yeah but
not people hate him because he can say
some [ __ ] that could sway politics and
ain't even saying people hating you
that's a problem because same people can
make rational decisions yeah it's there
are people who are insane out there
mentally ill people need something to
spend their time on yeah someone to
spend their time on yeah and if it's
this guy everybody says sucks all right
that's the guy yeah yeah yeah i mean
[ __ ] i don't think they will i think
that will smith should you know we're
not like oh community it's just like it
did
it put a rift in like the zeitgeist of
culture you know what i mean like it
just it did something i don't know what
but it did something and the fact that
that dave chappelle thing happened right
after it's like it did something yep
there was a move it moved that guy
wasn't doing that to dave if will didn't
do that first i agree and he knew he was
gonna get lumped the [ __ ] up but it was
worth the lumping for the attention it
was gonna give him and people are
willing to take these shots for
attention they saw nothing he goes oh
that's actually maybe the worst thing
that nothing happened will if will
got lumped up emotionally or in some way
the opposite happened yo he got
celebrated you sat there they all
clapped they had a [ __ ] standing
ovation for him and there is chris so so
and that is on chris and that is on
[ __ ] chris so so yo chris is
partially responsible for this happening
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
what i mean is he's not responsible for
this guy doing that to dave but the fact
that like no no pressing charges might
have been corny or something like that
but just like yo you can't come to oscar
for 10 years whatever corny [ __ ] that
was like that means you get all the
attention all the adulation because
please believe there are people in
certain communities that are saying that
guy that attacked dave he's a hero oh
yeah he's a hero so he got all the love
and attendance from the people that he
wants the love and attention from he
don't want it from the haters no he
wants it from the celebrators right so
he got all the love and attention he
wants now he got lumped the [ __ ] up and
it needs to be extra on top of that like
dude got to go to jail
well this is going to keep happening
what is the price you're willing to pay
for the clout if the price is low which
it was in bill smith uh will smith's
case other people are willing to pay
that price too i just walk around
slapping people and nothing happens to
me [ __ ] that's why they stopped showing
literally why they stopped showing
streakers during sports games like some
other street because they're like oh we
don't have enough punishment for this
but if we keep showing this it's going
to happen so much more yeah so now every
that's why it don't happen as much
anymore because every time it happens
they don't show it at all you know just
the camera will just shift or go to
commercial immediately same thing for
fights in the stands at boxing matches
yeah if will got [ __ ] up
chris if chris would have verbally just
[ __ ] him up right
just destroyed him i wish i could i wish
he just said the [ __ ] thing yeah that
would have set a precedent of like oh
there's something back in there or he
came out and said no i'm suing that
[ __ ] [ __ ] him
like if you just i don't care if you
think he's [ __ ] you know it's [ __ ]
just walk up to someone who you think
you're friendly with you know
yeah but not for real like just
something like that you're not going to
say that i would sue him for 100 million
dollars 100 and that's 100 what i would
have done yup
johnny depp's doing for 50 chris rocket
suit for 100. that [ __ ] was
millions of people so a billion people
saw chris rogers slept yep 100 million
is nothing yep it's like 10 cents a
person whatever the [ __ ] that is yeah
yeah i mean bro you're already on mount
rushmore and then the whole world's
perception changes of you yeah like
that's wild now you got to pay for that
i don't know if will comes back bro
that what the king richard we were
talking about earlier the king richard
was supposed to become because he felt
his movie sucked and then that was like
and he kills it i mean probably makes
you cry that it's such a great film and
then he for that hit so that was the
come up and then he threw it away oh you
definitely can't come back